we're doing a real experiment with a
fake identity earlier we created a fake
Social page on Facebook pretending to be
a freelance designer with a portfolio
and filled it with realistic posts let's
check if people online believe our
person is a real human we're looking for
art clubs in London yep let's apply to
these we fill in the details like we're
really passionate about art yes we got
accepted to some of the groups we write
in the chat and see if someone reacts to
our fake packaging and persona
wow Facebook is not dead some girl liked
our fake work we're gonna privately
message her got you she really accepted
my friend request and responded watch
the full video to see the results